everyone this is Kim from the chess
website calm today we're continuing our
coverage of the 2018 a st. Louis rapid
and blitz tournaments yesterday we
finished up the rapid portion there were
nine rounds of rapid played and today
starts the Blitz portion there's two
days and each day they played nine
rounds of blitz so quite a bit of chess
to be played for these 10 competitors
the scoring is a little bit different as
well in the blitz section and the rapid
we sell two points for a victory one
points for a draw zero points for a loss
in the blitz it's all half of that one
point for a win your standard scoring a
half a point for a draw and then zero
points for a loss
so just magnifies how important it was
in those rapid sections but today we
played nine rounds of blitz the players
had five minutes on their clocks they
were three seconds added every move that
they made near the top of leaderboard we
still have Nakamura and shiki at mama
did have and so today we're gonna be
looking at the game they played in blitz
around eight which is going to be around
17 overall of the tournament why it's
gonna be played by nakamura black is
going to be played by mom and dad I've
will go ahead and get started
Knight to f3 from Nakamura they're ready
opening pawn to d5 pawn to b3 Knight to
f6 at Bishop here to b2 upon g6 pawn to
g3 so it looks like both sides looking
to fee and headed there Bishop's to
either side of the board Bishop to a g7
pond up here to c4 after the capture
then pawn to b6 o more of a hyper modern
opening from both players trying to
control the center with their minor
pieces not looking to push forward with
their central pawns early into the game
Bishop to g2 getting ready to castle on
the King side as well Bishop to b7 so
neither side wanting their opponent to
control these long diagonals want to
make sure they have counter play with
their own bishops guess on the Kings
side and then pawn to c5
why that has a few options right here he
can't bring his knight to d2 doesn't
want to block off the bishop on c3 more
than likely gonna be pushing one of
these pawns as far as how he wants to
push he could play pawn to e3 if he
wants to pawn d3 or even pawn to d4 pawn
d4 I think gets a little trickier you
could see the pond take if the knight
takes right here then the bishop falls
on g2 yes both sides are exchanging
their bishops but nakamora does a good
job especially in these open games
controlling with his business not
looking to give up that bishop now if
you were to take with his own bishop
right here Knight to c6 this does lose a
little bit of a tempo that's why it's
gonna be forced to move back his bishop
so in the game we see Nakamura instead
just play this pawn to d3 so to find the
pawn term right here also opens up for
the night to come to d2 if Nakamura
wants to black plays castle on the King
side not here d2 and Knight to c6
getting that involved into the game
Queen to a b3 rook over here to e8
allowing for this pawn to push forward
and have control behind it here rook to
a d1 so both sides recognizing they need
to have sinner control right here
Queen to c7 opening up the door for the
rook to come to d8 the semi-open fouls I
always want to have your rooks in the
center or behind pawns you're pushing
forward or behind a semi-open file this
D file as an example where there's no
pawns and this rook can really control
this entire file here pawn to d3 this
just solidifies this control of the d4
square when there's a lot of us here all
on the board and no side is really
blinked yet as far as making a saying
where they want to go you really want to
figure out what squares are important
and a lot of action is going on around
this square here on d4 something like
pawn to e4 gets pretty tricky you can
start to see material push down here to
d4 little more difficult for white to
hold on to this since he has no pawns
that can protect it and so wants to make
sure he controls this square before he
get
commits to anything out so he plays pawn
to e3 and rook to d8 just attacking the
square that we talked about then you
start to look at you know what your
opponent can do here then I can't come
to d4 since that pawns there but it can
come to b4 and so Nakamura decides to
play pawn to a3 sometimes just stopping
your opponent from doing anything is the
best offense black moves back to queen
c8 could have also played pawn East six
or a five both of those are reasonable
but decided to move his Queen back
before he pushes with his central pawn
rook to e1 centralizing Queen a8
attacking this long light square
diagonal Queen to c2 rook here d7 pawn
pushing forward efore this is an
interesting move from Nakamura wanting
to push in the center but recognizing
that this does now give him a backward
pawn here on d3 that black can attack
also opens up for black to come down and
attack on d4 if he wants to black now
comes in plays Knight to g4 Bishop takes
on g7 we do see the bishops exchange on
the board Bishop to h3 attacking the
knight and then pawn to h5 it's almost
seems like when black recognized that
the pond pushed forward little weakness
in the structure of white black
immediately just got pretty aggressive
started to push on the King side of the
board pawn now pushes forward to e5 and
then rook to d8 so this is an
interesting spot because I think black
should look at this and really try to
stop his opponent from pushing further
he has the rook back here on e 1 part of
the reason you had this is to push the
pawns and half support here it can come
up to e6 and really start to put a lot
of pressure on black something like pawn
to e6 really just stops that right away
and just says okay I have a good
structure right here how are you going
to continue but in the game decided to
play rook to d8 Nakamura continues to
push pani 6 then we have the rook come
coming down here taking the pawn on d3
pawn takes on f7
and then the pond pushes forward on e5
could have just taken with this king but
then things get tricky when night comes
up here g5 check really starts to get
aggressive for white so in the game
after pawn takes on f7 we C pawn to e5
white continues with Knight to g5
defending this square here on f7 Queen
over to c8 preparing for Queen to f5
this is also protecting the night here
on a g4 lack of more pushes pawn to f3
attacking the knight and then the Queen
comes down here to f5 would be a huge
mistake for white to take here although
it looks like it is open but then black
has the great move of rook to g3 check
this is a discovered attack on the Queen
c2 after you know the pawn takes and the
Queen comes down takes on c2 definitely
going to be a big mistake so after the
Queen comes down we see Knight to e4
centralizing the knight
rook takes on d2 the night their rook
takes and then that comes down here to
d4 and this is a great outpost from
black it's a little easier for black to
take the night here on e4 the outpost
because it slice where Bishop but the
night here on d4 attacking the Queen and
white cannot remove this with his own
Bishop because the dark Choi Bishop is
off the board this is another spot where
it'd be a bad idea for the pond to take
here you could probably see a little
easier the knight can come down to f3
forking the King check after the King
moves then we could see Knight take here
on a1 and then maybe the pawn takes the
Queen then rook comes down here
attacking the Queen Queen takes and then
we could see Bishop coming down here
efore check after the King moves then
all of a sudden we have Knight to f3
another fork attacking the Queen and
that's going to fall blacks gonna be up
big in this position so white does not
correctly again take the knight here on
a g4 instead decides to go ahead and
take his rook here on d4 just got a rook
for his own Knight so decides hey this
outpost is enough for me to go ahead and
give
back that material right here and now
the rook comes down and takes on d4 now
open to the spot Nakamura has correctly
found that taking the night here on g4
was the incorrect play but in this spot
he thought the time was right and he was
wrong he played pawn takes on a g4 now
the bishop comes down takes on e4
attacking the Queen right here
white hasn't in between move decides
okay this pawn up here isn't doing much
I'm gonna go ahead and sacrifice it
pushes forward just to get another Queen
sometimes you just want to let your
opponent know do you have two Queens on
the board doesn't really matter King
takes here on f8 Queen to e2 since it
was under attack pawn takes on g4 Bishop
takes Queen over here to g5 you can see
that black is up a pawn and material
also has a much more aggressive position
than his opponent h4 then the Queen
comes back here to e7 Queen to e3 King
g7 h 5y trying to push as much as
possible but black doing a good job of
defending correctly keeping his
advantage Bishop takes here [ __ ] comes
back to g6 then we see Bishop f3 rook
down here to d3 attacking the Queen it
is being protected by the bishop here on
g6 and you can really see that black is
continuously pushing and pushing trying
to extend his position if he can start
to just exchanging material off the
board he should have an easy endgame
Queen comes down here to e2 and then we
see what could be the changing point in
the tournament we'll see how things in
but black looks at this he has an easy
move I think as far as just continuing
gobbling up material taking here on a3
should have an easy game he plays pawn
to e4 which looks like it's a decent
move he only had a few seconds left in
the game so recognizing that in these
type of games many times you make
mistakes
surely out of time but if he looks at
this and says I have a queen I have a
big
both defending this square right here
things should be good unfortunately that
would be incorrect because what Shakir
did not see is the move Queen takes on
d3 and then the pawn can't actually take
it's a great deflection from Nakamura
recognizing that pawn can take Kajin the
rooks are just gonna come up here and
take it the Queen right here and you
know also if the pawn comes and takes
right here
the Queen is going to fall as well so
white is able to just gobble up that
rook for free and now it's going to be a
very easy in game for Nakamura so I felt
like Shakir played a phenomenal game
against an opponent is extremely
aggressive with the white pieces and at
the very end time got him in this blitz
section made a critical error and at the
end Nakamura ended up winning so that
was in round 8 of the blitz portion they
did play one more round and at the end
of the ninth round so we've played 18
total rounds of chess so far these two
players are tied for first so going into
tomorrow they will be going at each
other again to see who is going to be
the champion of the entire tournament
have to get through quite a lot of
competitors but they will face off again
tomorrow
so we'll see how that goes but
congratulations to Nakamura for
capitalizing when his opponent made a
mistake many times that's exactly what
you have to do in these types of
tournaments so hopefully you guys are
enjoying the rapid in blitz portion see
so many different openings and see some
mistakes which we don't always get to
see at the highest level play so thanks
for watching I'll see you guys in the
next video tomorrow